now in the 1960s and 1970s the french
government
took away nearly 2 000 children from the
island of reunion
that's one of france's overseas
territories in the indian ocean
their plan was to repopulate rural areas
of mainland france
and the children were promised education
and opportunity
instead many injured years of
mistreatment now reunions generation of
stolen children
want the french government to pay
damages for their suffering
even at the age of 75 emil benoit oro
still bears the deep scars left by his
youth
the government took him away from his
family at the age of nine as part of a
resettlement program
he was first sent to various children's
homes on the island of reynion
we weren't allowed to say or do anything
we had to follow the supervisor's orders
if we didn't they hit us they made us do
hard labor at one point
we had to carry buckets of cement on our
heads and pour them onto a slab
to build a swimming pool somewhere the
walls around the homes were four meters
high
we weren't allowed to go out or to see
our families
he was told he would be taken to
mainland france but
it took another nine years and instead
of getting a good education there
as promised he had to work as a farmhand
we had to milk the cows clean the pig
pens plant and harvest beetroot and
potatoes
the farmers had been told we were
dangerous that we were murderers
and thieves they didn't trust us and
treated us like slaves
so they hit us at the slightest excuse
he was finally freed at the age of 21
and managed to set up a business as a
painter
he tried to forget his past as best he
could
up until a few years ago when he met his
partner mariju
she insisted he needed to find his roots
he's 75 now he has lived most of his
life but i hope he still has much longer
to live at least 10 or 15 years
and i want him to be happy during that
time
she searched for months sent hundreds of
emails and
managed to get one spectacular result
she found emil's older sister marie who
lives on reynion
they talk to each other daily
i was always hoping to find him and
never gave up my search
now he's too far away from me i want him
to come back here
in 2014 france officially acknowledged
its moral responsibility towards the
so-called children of the cross
the ministry of the overseas told us
that they plan
to teach these children's history at
school but emil is hoping for more
we are asking for damages that's
perfectly reasonable
they have done us harm if i had robbed
or killed someone
i would also be punished even though
money will not right the wrong they have
done to us
it's like losing a leg you'll never get
it back
but previous claims for compensation
were dismissed
due to the statute of limitations emil
will keep looking for his happiness
he's planning to go to reno this autumn
to finally reunite with his family